pas
[Musique]
c'est par un processus simple mais
redoutablement efficace que j'ai décidé
il ya quelques années de me lancer dans
une aventure absolument inédite
une aventure qui allait m'amener
jusqu'aux limites du possible
et j'irais même jusqu'à dire d'une
certaine manière
jusqu'aux frontières du réel ce
processus il tient en quelques étapes et
nous allons les partager ensemble
je vais vous demander de prendre une
grande inspiration et d'imaginer et
maintenant vous imaginez demandez vous
et moi dans tout ça
eh oui
et maintenant que vous vous demandez et
moi dans tout ça dites-vous simplement
et alors
bah quoi non mais où aller et au et une
fois que vous êtes dit et au fait vous
juste la réflexion et ben tiens pourquoi
pas ça marche ça marche je vous ai déjà
quelques visage s'éclairer dans la salle
le 8 février 2016 grâce à la puissance
de cette méthode
j'allais enfin réaliser un exploit
encore jamais accompli à ce jour pour la
première fois au monde je parvenais à
descendre en apnée sans aucun apport
d'oxygène et à la seule force de mon
index droit au fond tout au fond d'un
tableur excel
alors l'image que vous voyez derrière
moi été prise quelques minutes avant mon
départ
on le voit entouré de quelques collègues
et je dois dire que si l'exploit est
incontestablement individuelle et bien
l' aventure elle est collective et sans
la présence d'une équipe de
collaborateurs à ses côtés il ne serait
jamais possible de descendre aussi bas
c'est important de le rappeler
là vous me voyez juste après ma remontée
dans ces moments là c'est évidemment la
joie qui domine l'eau faurie je viens de
revenir jusqu'à la cellule à 1
la cellule de surface familière
rassurante une cellule que nous
connaissons tous et dans laquelle je
viens de reprendre enfin mon souffle
après plus de quarante minutes et 50
secondes d'apnée ce qui évidemment n'est
pas rien ce sont donc ces incroyables et
vibrante minutes passées dans
l'immensité d'un tableur que j'aimerais
vous faire revivre ce soir 1 millions 48
milles 576 ligne c'est la profondeur
exacte d'un tableur excel
alors quand on évolue en surface dans
les dix en première ligne tout au plus
pour un utilisateur moyen on ne se rend
pas toujours compte de ce qu'il ya en
dessous mais un million 48 milles 576
ligne à raison d'un demi centimètre par
cellule je vous laisse faire le calcul
ce n'est pas moins d'un million 48
milles 576 demi centimètre qui se
déploie sous le curseur de votre souris
ou encore si on prend le temps de faire
la conversion correctement 524 1280 8 cm
entier
ou encore ce qui est plus parlant 5242 m
et des bananes 5242 m la juste sous
votre doigt
plus que 250 fois la hauteur qui vous
sépare de ce magnifique plafond vous
regardiez tout à l'heure plus que la
hauteur du mont blanc est presque la
moitié de la fosse des mariannes la
fosse océanique la plus profonde au
monde
de quoi donner le vertige non en tout
cas de quoi faire rêver l'aventurier de
bureau que je suis et lui donner envie
d'aller découvrir toute l'étendue de ces
territoires encore inexplorés
en réalité j'ai commencé l'apnée
bureautique beaucoup plus tôt dans les
années 90 à l'époque où les tableurs
n'était profond que de quelques
centaines de lignes à cette période je
me souviens ont plongé avec la simple
flèche on ne pratiquait pas encore ce
qu'on appelle le no limit qui consiste à
utiliser la double flèche pour descendre
beaucoup plus vite
alors évidemment cette technique qui
s'est avérée très efficace s'est aussi
révélé au fil du temps beaucoup plus
dangereuse pour les plongeurs et là je
suis bien obligé d'évoquer l'accident
qui m'est arrivé en juillet 2014 lors de
ma toute première tentative pour
atteindre le fond d'excel ce jour là
j'ai bien failli ne jamais remonter
victime à la fois d'une ivresse des
profondeurs et d'une terrible crampes à
mon index droit comme en témoigne la
seule image d'archivés qui nous reste
autant dire que je ne suis pas passé
loin du drame
mais cet échec ne m'a pas découragé
au contraire parce que vous le savez on
vous l'a beaucoup dit à tedx et ailleurs
on apprend énormément de ses échecs et
comme disait einstein
rien n'est plus proche du vrai que le
faut alors ça n'a rien à voir mais ça me
plaisait de placer cette citation à cet
endroit
ce que je trouve que c'est quelque chose
que l'on ne se perd mais oui
c'est vrai c'est quelque chose que l'on
ne se permet que trop rarement sa de
placer n'importe quel citation à
n'importe quel endroit et franchement
c'est dommage parce que c'est très
libérateur verrez vous essaierez bon
mais laissons un petit peu de côté les
expériences difficiles et revenons à
cette plongée réussie du bi février 2016
est pour vous la faire vivre au plus
près de la façon dont je l' ai vécu je
vais solliciter encore une fois votre
participation et je vais vous demander
de fermer les yeux puis de les rouvrir
puis de les fermer à nouveau puis de les
rouvrir
et puis de finalement choisir en
connaissance de cause si vous voulez les
garder ouverts parce que je sais que de
toute façon quelle que soit la consigne
vous finissez toujours par faire ce que
vous voulez donc autant que ça soit déjà
dans la consigne
tiens d'ailleurs ce soir vous pouvez
même choisir de ne pas choisir comme
c'est la fin de journée et vous pouvez
par exemple cligner des yeux comme ça
très vite pour voir la suite de mon
intervention comme dans une boîte de
nuit
pourquoi pas c'est fatigant mais ça peut
être très festif aussi bref vous êtes
bien maintenant
projetez-vous mais vraiment comme si
vous y étiez dans ses tous derniers
instants qui précèdent la descente
vous êtes devant votre écran
d'ordinateur
bien calé dans votre cellule à
vous vous préparez et au bout d'un
moment grâce à un phénomène que nous
maîtrisons tous mais que mobilisons que
trop rarement l'inspiration vous êtes en
mesure d'entamer votre descente vous
bloquez votre souffle vous appuyez sur
la double flèche du bas et c'est parti
après vous être littéralement arraché de
la surface vous descendez maintenant
avec beaucoup plus de fluidité en une
minute à peine vous avez dépassé les
cinquante mille à cette profondeur il
n'ya bien sûr plus un chiffre plus
rien juste l'immensité du tableur soupe
aux yeux c'est un sentiment à la fois
d'humilité et d'humidité qui vous
envahit vous êtes dans les grandes
profondeurs
cent mille deux cent mille cinq cent
mille lignes vous continuer à descendre
et vous avez juste l'impression d'être
un tout petit point dans le grand
ordinateur de la fille
little queen teen de big computer of
life vous continuer à descendre toujours
et encore c'est grisant et plus que de
les faire bouger les lignes vous avez
l'impression de les faire danser ouais
c'est ça c'est l'impression qui vous
traversent à ce moment là celle de faire
danser les lignes vous continuer à
descendre
huit cent mille neuf cent mille à un
million de lignes vous êtes bientôt à
votre but
et soudain
ou plutôt après 20 minutes
une descente vertigineuse vous êtes à la
cellule à 1 millions 48 milles 576 le
fond du tableur
hélas pour que l'expérience soit totale
je vais vous demander d'arrêter de
respirer pendant quelques secondes
vous êtes là dans cet ultime cellules et
vous réalisez à ce moment là que le
point d'inflexion
il est là celui où il va falloir sans
tarder inverser le mouvement et
commencez votre remontée mais à ce
moment là vous n'avez aucune envie de
revenir la surface vous êtes juste bien
vous regardez autour de vous en
particulier sur votre droite et vous
vous dites qu'il ya là aussi
certainement des espaces infinis aller
explorer des colonnes à n'en plus finir
a b c d e f g jusqu'à z puis à a jusqu'à
hasebe abe z c'est assez x et z xx tedx
aaa à aa
hélas l'ivresse des profondeurs comment
ça vous envahira nouveau une multitude
de penser s'enchaînent dans votre tête à
une vitesse folle
vous pensez au big bang à la liste de
courses de la semaine à ce foutu
encodage de votre mémoire à long terme
que vous n'arrivez toujours pas faire
correctement et l'histoire d'un instant
vous vous croyez même apercevoir des
baleines nagent et devant vos yeux
c'est un moment d'intense n'importe quoi
mais à n'importe quoi qui fait du bien
vous êtes suivre bloqué dans votre
cellule mais libre et puis soudain c'est
le diving réflexe un réflexe que nous
avons tous en commun avec les grands
mammifères marins votre doigt pourtant
tétanisé est passé sans que vous vous en
rendiez compte sur la flèche du haut et
vous avez déjà entamé votre remontée
vingt minutes plus tard vous retrouver
la surface le visage ébahis de vos
collègues et c'est l'explosion de joie
tel que vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure
on l'a fait on est descendu au fond
d'extrême
alors une question ou bien peut-être à
l'esprit tout de suite mais qu'est ce
qu'il ya à retenir de cette histoire
c'est quoi le thé que wade du talk qui
va faire que vous sortiez d'ici un peu
plus intelligent que vous n'êtes venu
vous dire qu'ils vont bien bassiner avec
ça les coaches tedx c'est quoi tenter
que ouais bon sa tente et que ouais un
petit peu ce point douter que oui
là je suis un tout de même assez
embarrassée parce que je pense que ce
talk n'a aucune vocation à vous rendre
plus intelligent au contraire il est
même là je crois pour vous délester un
peu
de toute cette intelligence accumulés
tout au long de l'après midi
parce que je vous ai vu moi réfléchir
vous posez des questions évoluer sur un
tas de sujets mais franchement je trouve
pas ça très raisonnable de s'envoyer des
doses pareil d'intelligence un samedi
après-midi en plus alors que vous
pourriez être dans les magasins ou au
stade marcel michelin à l'heure qu'il
est parce que en plus le problème c'est
que pendant que vous deveniez plus
intelligent le monde dehors
il n'a pas changé
alors ça risque de vous faire un petit
peu bizarre en sortant
donc un conseil les 16 ans un peu ici de
cette intelligence et si vous vous êtes
vraiment délester si vous gardez une
certaine fantaisie et peut-être même un
peu d'attrait pour le n'importe quoi
je suis sûr que la prochaine fois que
vous ouvrirez votre tableur
vous serez peut-être tentés d'aller voir
un peu plus bas comment ça se passe
et et avec un peu de chance avec un peu
de chance et si vous êtes vraiment
attentifs vous verrez peut-être des
baleines passer devant vos yeux
alors bonne plongé à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]